uh who's i was talking with someone
might have been my girlfriend we were
like
talking about who could have done ace
ventura besides jim carrey
no one but did you know the force gump
you know uh bubble gump they they uh
reached out to ice cube to play bubble
gump
wait wait wait and did you know john
travolta was supposed to be forescout
but he turned it down and then tom hanks
got it
wait really what did you also know that
tom hanks when they were filming it
they didn't want to pay for the running
scene in one of the other scenes
and tom hanks went i'll pay for it but
if it does well you got to give me this
much money and then went yeah cool this
movie's probably not going to do that
well
so he made like double bag oh dude
because he paid for the run scene in
another scene he got
in different states yeah yeah so and he
goes i'll front it
but i i want this percentage on the back
and they signed off that dude i cried at
the bubba gump scene
man every time that movies
dude can we talk about jenny being a
[ __ ] i hate
we talking about good guys look how
these women break dude
yeah come on yes yeah i'm alive from
i love it when he whips that guy's ass
right and then they kick him out the
black panther meeting and them
he's so stupid and then the next day
they're getting on the bus
and uh he's all jenny i love you and
she's like foresee how you get going
and she's like we're gonna go and he
looks at me so to greenbow alabama
and then just keep stammies
i love that movie that movie was great
he went he won oscar out there correct
right
i think he won every award everyone
changing yeah that was great movie was
[ __ ] great
oh the big story of tom hanks paying for
certain
uh scenes like made him rich beyond
belief yeah he won everything
which it should and you said
philadelphia with him and denzel is a
great one
dude denzel's so good in that yeah
oh it's because drops the f-bomb in that
a bunch
the word that rhymes with rhymes with
with
maggots it rhymes with maggots he drops
the f-bomb a lot oh cause of the ace
and because at first he doesn't like
like gay dudes he's like man i'm not
trying to blah blah blah with maggots
and then
by the end of it he's like the number
one supporter it's dope oh wow that's
cool
i gotta watch it yeah that's a great
thing i got uh goodwill hunting
have you ever seen milk uh with uh sean
penn
true story it was a guy who's running
for office in san francisco he's a
first gotta run for office in san
francisco he ends up a spoiler but also
history so not a spoiler he gets
assassinated no
mm-hmm oh damn it's called he's like
fighting for gay rights he's in san
francisco during hate ashbury times have
you seen it chin
no i remember the story though oh crazy
it was a harvey
i think oh really it's like in the heat
like every there's protests everything
and
cops used to come into the gay district
and just beat the [ __ ] out of people for
being gay
damn yeah harvey milk
sean penn's so good in that and his
boyfriend's uh
uh homeboy that did uh disaster movie
how does sean penn look at
him because he kind of i could see sean
uh yeah
oh sean penn looks a spot on and he's
yeah i can see him like look dude his
voice
it's crazy how great his voice is wow
that is kind of crazy
though milk's a great movie man oh wow
yeah it's real
it's fascinating too he's in san
francisco he's fighting for gay rights
all right i got some movies to watch
check it out dude that goodwill hunting
in philadelphia
i'm gonna watch philadelphia i'm gonna
watch philadelphia milk you should watch
straight out of compton
i bet i've seen more movies than you
guys i'm a movie connoisseur i love
movies
you haven't seen you ever seen angus oh
no yeah we talked about this you've
never seen
this you don't want to go see anger
you're an [ __ ]
when i get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son